if a mouse wearing a hat ran into my
home right now i'd move
i would pack and i would leave and i'd
never come back i wouldn't be like oh
yeah
sweep
be better disney princesses i'm here
with tom menino to talk about the worst
character traits of the disney
princesses finally those princesses are
gonna get it
so my pick
for the worst character traits of the
disney princesses
uh
i struggled with this because
it's hard to pick
it's just hard to pick what can i say
it's hard to choose there are so many
terrible traits
no the the best thing i could come up
with is that i think that they're too
trusting of of animals they always seem
to have
at least one animal companion that's
just like always down for whatever
adventure they're on and i'm just kind
of like have you met animals animals are
not cooperative that you need to you
need to have special trainers just to
get them to you know
do the thing that they're supposed to
sometimes they carry disease often in
the wild yeah often not safe you know
right when um which one had all the
animals help her do all the all the
chores in her house
cinderella was that snow white
cinderella i think it was it could have
been cinderella it was cinderella
cinderella cinderelly right all little
mice yes yes
come on
it's disgusting
if a mouse wearing a hat ran into my
home right now i'd move
i would pack and i would leave and i'd
never come back
i wouldn't be like oh yeah
i mean
you're in paris so i assume it would be
a beret
i would assume yeah
would that change anything or no no did
you just shut down ratatouille as a
possibility for your wife
pat knows well it's a gentleman yeah i
would love for pat oswalt to cook in my
home not a rat
they carry disease
a lot of it
so yeah so that's that's my pick they
are often they often have an animal
sidekick or two
and they're just
you know why like you can get by without
some random animal like it's and they
always pick the weirdest animals too
tangled she just has a chameleon for
some reason
is that just where she lives i don't i
mean i don't think so i
was confused by that too i was like
where'd they get this it's just an odd
choice it's a little they run out of
animals
they were like well we've done mice
we've done birds
we've done raccoons hummingbirds
crickets
dragons
right the very common
woodland creature luck dragon so i guess
iguana or chameleon rather is it i think
it's a chameleon no it's a comedian
because he like changes colors
anyway that's my pick they're too
trusting of animals i don't trust
animals i never will trust animals
that's my pick nina
what is your pick for the worst
character traits of disney princesses
first of all i do think we need to maybe
change the name under brian to say brian
rubin colin does not trust animals
i think we can bring that kid
i would love to see that either we'll do
that either we'll do that or this whole
section will be cut
perfect we'll see we'll find out so
brian to i took a different approach to
this but i do want to leap frog off of
what you said as a generalized bad
personality trait which is that they are
all just
extremely
just not even passive aggressive there's
no aggression they're just passive like
everything happens like you know
cinderella's stepsisters and stepmother
like you can't go to the ball like stay
home and stick the floor and she's like
well my legs don't work i can't walk
there
oh no whatever shall i do and like she
has to wait around for her fairy
godmother and then of course she pulls
off the most famous irish exit in in
history
the irish goodbye yeah yeah yeah a
favorite of bar flies everywhere so yeah
i mean
ariel's like oh no why can't i talk to a
human male i'm like put your head above
water and talk to them
this isn't hard
snow white never says or does anything
of importance to be honest but the the
biggest bone i have to pick and this
really kind of hurts because as a kid i
really loved beauty and the beast
and i was a kid who read a lot and so i
really identified with belle it's like
the bookworm princess or whatever
but man she is a jerk she just walks
around her village every single morning
singing the rudest song i've ever heard
she's like look at these dumb
crappy people living their lives in this
beautiful french village oh i gotta get
out of here this sucks but she says
hello yeah she says hello and
immediately segways into there's the guy
doing the same thing he does every day
what a loser and then just keeps going
i mean provincial am i right no
no wonder nobody in her town likes her i
wouldn't i'd be like
there is a famous tweet that gave that
like i took inspiration from where it's
like you know villagers there goes belle
singing her daily mean song about us and
i'm just imagining this and i'm like
yeah i understand why she's unpopular
and everyone thinks she's weird because
she walks around the town just saying
just offensive things to everybody
whereas yes gaston is objectively a
bigger jerk but he at least
sucks up to everybody a little bit he's
of the people yeah he tries she's just
like
you know screw all of you i'm getting
out of here oh okay what are you gonna
do go to college bill it's like 1 500.
no she's gonna unless a beast kidnaps
you you're really not going anywhere
she's gonna go live with it with a
the giant demon whatever get off your
eyeballs
i'm sick of belle i don't like belle's
attitude
i like her her general vibe of of being
learned and reading books and being
really jazzed about libraries but i
don't like her her crappy attitude
and her judgmental
instincts so
i'm gonna go ahead and pick bill
and then
i don't even really know where to start
with a character like ariel
so
yeah
fair enough just
not great where do we even go from there
well i know where we should go let's go
to tom tom what's your pick for the
worst character traits as disney
princesses
i want to start out by thanking you for
giving me the opportunity as a 33 year
old straight guy to talk on the internet
about disney princesses at great length
this is clearly
my comfort zone
[Music]
and i've been looking forward to it
thank you nina
hi nina
i don't know very much about this i i
thought kind of a
a little bit out of my element um
i do think that it's it's maybe a little
bit dismissive to say like what's the
worst trait of all of the disney
princesses which was which was my read
on the prompt i don't know if i did that
correctly
um so instead i decided that we should
probably look at all of them just real
quick um
i had a no this is just a smack in the
white board today i just would i just
want to do like a really quick one it's
like it's not it's not a huge deal i'm
assuming that by disney princess we're
talking about like the branded
trademarked disney princess logo which
uh we mean like the uh the 12 official
disney princesses starting out of course
with the original snow white my big
problem with her all of her best friends
are dudes that's kind of a red flag
cinderella all of my best friends are
rats
double red flag
uh
sleeping beauty i didn't like have a
huge problem with aurora the big problem
is that she only has 18 lines in the
movie i don't know if you know that but
she doesn't really do anything we don't
know who this is as a character the
prince doesn't know who she is as a
character is she racist we don't know we
never find out so like
sketchy is all by the way
i do want to point out that these top
four right here they do all fall into a
category that i have branded needs to uh
to your original point needs to stop
trusting wild animals and old magic
women or in case of aerial
drag royalty uh jasmine
shout out to devine jasmine is a uh she
is a wealthy
one percenter vacations by pretending
that she's a poor person that seems kind
of problematic
that's perfect
pocahontas she does fall in love with
mel gibson in the movie which is
nobody's favorite trait and anybody else
so she has a voldemort nose
mulan killed a lot of people in that
movie she decides that i don't have like
a ton of issues with her aside from that
my little sister had the soundtrack for
the movie and she played it like on
repeat for about six months and there's
only so much donnie osmond that you can
stand also all of her best friends are
dudes red flag
ariel
ariel's 16 years old she's illiterate
she only understands love is either like
an abstract fantasy that she builds up
in her head like without having anything
real to back it up or as
a series of giant sacrifices that people
make for when her dad gets turned into a
worm and she's like oh he finally likes
me speaking
to her dad she still calls him daddy at
16 which is
uh
yeah he constantly puts her friends in
danger she ain't even knows what forts
is i i could go on about ariel she's got
a lot going on bad table matters at the
very least yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
belle uh
i hate to argue with you nina she seems
cool
the original hipster
she's she reads a lot she like uh
she seems kind of like what is she
better than everyone else
kind of she i mean like a little bit she
sees a hair
like so i think we've got some insight i
think i could fix him and type something
about that that speaks to me nina i
think we know now what tom does every
morning when he goes out for his morning
stroll he just goes out and goes oh look
at this loser like just out loud
singing
[Music]
instead of instead of drinking coffee
tom does that it gives him the energy he
needs for his day
that's more or less it unless
unless you guys want to
keep talking about ariel
if you want do you want to keep talking
about ariel sounds like you want to i
don't know how much time we have are we
okay on time right now we're up great on
time you go right ahead
[Laughter]
so i'm sorry this will just
this part's a little
shaky here wow
so
[Music]
it looks great this is such a game
[Music]
but i think that there are better female
role models for young women
by way of example
oh my god what
nina correct me if i'm wrong but i
believe that it was in season 12 episode
9 grey's anatomy the episode titled
the sound of silence written by stacy
mckee and of course directed by denzel
washington
we have to cut all this don't we
maybe we'll see
go on where one dr meredith gray said
after being attacked by a patient and
losing her ability to speak for the
majority of the episode she said you
have a voice
use it speak up raise your hands
shout your answers
make yourself heard
whatever it takes just find your voice
and when you do
fill the damn silence
i leave you with that
wow also at the bottom right here it
says i never saw tangled or moana or
brave or the princess and frogs i really
don't have anything to say about that
bye everybody
bye
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe so you don't miss a single
video